and so we're very delighted to that
National Geographic has been an early
partner with the GigaPan conference and
through collaboration among the CMU's
create lab National Geographic and NASA
the global connection project was formed
and some of you may know the global
connection project provides a whole new
interactive way for people to learn
about and meet their neighbors from
across the globe educating people about
distant places and cultures has been a
hallmark of National Geographic for more
than a century a mark Baumann our
speaker for tonight is the executive
vice president of National Geographic
television and he is from his time at
National Geographic enthusiastically
embraced the potential of GigaPan to
advance national Geographics mission and
has encouraged its use among their staff
photographers so c mu 0 National
Geographic have long been at work
improving cultural understanding and
solving real problems through the power
of new types of imaging so we're very
fortunate to have him here to speak on a
national geographic and gigapixel
imaging a marks work at National
Geographic is the latest chapter in what
has been a steam career in journalism
prior to joining National Geographic
about ten years ago mark was based in
Eastern Europe and Latin America where
he ran Baghdad and Balkan coverage for
ABC News he's provided coverage of wars
in central Africa Lebanon Bosnia
Afghanistan and Iraq for major media
outlooks and outlets including ABC BBC
CNN NPR and leading metropolitan
newspapers across the US and around the
world he's our numerous awards and
honors for broadcast and print
journalism including an Emmy Award so
it's my pleasure to introduce our
speaker for tonight mark balan
Wow it's an honor to be here tonight and
to be the warm-up band for the
incredible array of speakers that it was
lined up for you across the next few
days I see a bunch of events that i wish
i was going to be at tomorrow and
saturday I've seen a lot of the
incredibly cool things that people have
done with GigaPan technologies so I
don't kid myself that that some of the
stuff I'm about to offer you is new or
revolutionary but the thing I love about
still photography is that it has the
power to connect the head and the heart
and as I think most of you know gigapan
technology in the GigaPan interface sort
of ramps up the toolset you've got
available to you on both fronts why is
National Geographic interested these are
the things that we focus on lately and I
think it it hits on every major priority
that we have as an institution
geographic and global literacy media
literacy scientific literacy and one of
the things that I'm most excited about
recently is crowd-sourced science and
citizen participation science i think
that is no secret that we've gone
through a couple of periods recently
where science has been devalued as part
of the public debate and i sure would
like to see people connected to it more
palpably and i think this is one great
technology that's moving people in the
right direction we've worked with with
illa and and roar on a number of things
recently but one of the things that I've
enjoyed most is that we've staged photo
camps and understood in underserved
communities that focus on scientific and
cultural literacy and what surprised me
about this technology which is primarily
primarily digital
is that it works for people on the wrong
side of the digital divide this photo
you see right here was taken on an
Indian Reservation in South Dakota where
they don't have much broadband and these
guys created posted stickers so that
they could start to meta tag their
community and areas inside their
community and start to learn about the
power of photography and its ability to
connect them to their own community
we're also using gigapixel imaging to
allow the public to explore environments
that you just can't see with your own
two eyes so we see if this six-year-old
laptop will get me back to where I need
to go a couple of years ago Mike Fay who
most of you have probably met walked to
transect from the southernmost redwood
tree to the northernmost a linear
distance of 700 miles although as Mike
will probably tell you he didn't walk it
in a straight line in 1850 old-growth
redwoods occupied two million acres at
the California folks but after a lot of
people failed to strike it rich in the
gold rush out there they started logging
the giant trees to fill to fuel the
building boom out there and by 1968
nearly ninety percent of the original
redwood trees have been logged National
Geographic Mike macnicols is his partner
in crime wanted people to think about
these magnificent trees and how we could
preserve and even expand their range so
as part of the article that Mike wrote
Nick Nichols produced the first ever
high-definition seamless composite
photograph of an entire redwood tree now
this tree right here 300 feet tall and
somewhere between 1500 and 2000 years
old Nick believes Nick believes that
this could be the most complex
architectural tree in the world and you
you can't see it this way in nature you
can stand at the bottom and look up if
you were on a rope line you could see
little pieces
it but essentially what Nick had to do
is create a for camera array and and and
and drop it if three feet at a time and
take 84 photos and put them together now
as you can see we've got a really cool
high-resolution image of this tree which
we hope will connect both hearts and
minds but we have a really clumsy
interface and one of the things that
we're talking about doing is putting all
of our gigapixel images into the GigaPan
site because right now well I've got it
loaded up on this computer a pretty low
resolution but you can you can dive into
any piece of this tree you want to look
at the leaves in a lot of these trees
the leaves that fall actually create
mulch areas up high and other trees
start to grow I mean they're frauds and
ecosystems that exist in the canopy that
would be great for kids to experience
there are a whole lot of environments on
the planet that you just can't
necessarily experience with the naked
eye or then you can't see fully from
anywhere a few years ago Kenny broad and
West Skiles who was one of the bravest
underwater photographers in the world
wanted to share the dark and toxic blue
hole environments of the Bahamas with a
broader public and they they knew that
the most effective way to do that was
with a gigapixel image I mean these are
caverns and and when you light a piece
of them you only see you know a few feet
at a time so can he spent a whole lot of
time figuring out how to do this and and
then I mean this is one of the last
photographs he ever took
photograph here's the deterrent hi Dalin
that work and my goal was to capture an
image that translates the audience what
deals
all on the lower case Todd is hard we
have no real communication
they are
team to operate lights and strobes and
perform complex and difficult dodging
the universe this is a complex picture I
had to figure out a way to a transect
line that would allow me to keep the
camera at st. death and the same angle
in a cave I had to find this spot do
this I took it as a series of
photographs only the Central Corridor
will be lit and that above it would be
black and the low would be black West
took great risk in these forests for
long narrow compositions he stitched
picture after picture together so fly to
make this compelling image that captures
the mystery
a assignment like this my photo
countless 34,000 a great photograph is
pure magic it's amazing how sellin
actually occurs I chose West as pitcher
because it takes us to a place will
never see it's a celebration of the
diversity of the world is the
celebration exploration
so that Wes Kyle's photo and the Nick
Nichols photo we're both full doubts in
our magazine and people could hold them
experience them you know in a tactile
way but as more of our magazine
subscribers migrate platforms like the
iPad it's become critical that we offer
them value-added experiences and richer
ways to experience our photography and
in ways that they can engage in dialogue
with it and around it I think the sky's
the limit on this stuff I think there
aren't people out there or there are
very few people out there who don't want
to participate in expeditions I think we
can use this technology to do species
counts one of my colleagues from the
camp we did 18 months ago has been using
it for B counts I know Mike's been
thinking about using it for elephant
counts along with satellite data for
archaeology and paleontology it's an
amazing technology particularly with
aerial platforms and in the public
engagement piece is really what appeals
to me what we would like to see I mean I
think every year we're going to launch
expeditions that have that allow the
public to be virtual participants and
help us find pyramid sites and then help
us meta tag well start with the
satellite data identify the sites and
then meta tag all of the artifacts in
situ in 3d we'd love to create 3d
environments for exhibits that kids can
walk through I mean that Tut interactive
we've played with in a star cave
environment and
and done 3d versions of it but you can
imagine kids in inner-city schools that
can't afford to go to a lot of the great
sites on the planet being able to walk
through them anyway being able to
experience them online and to repeat the
discoveries that we've all been part of
but more importantly I think to be part
of the discoveries I mean the ability to
meta tag this stuff and to capture more
data than you can in a single photograph
so that none of us when we take you
japan are even aware of all that's there
opens up the opportunity for discovery
and that's what excites me so we've
talked to nasa about crowdsourcing the
exploration of galaxies but there's a
lot on this planet still left to
discover and for us anyway gigapixel
imaging and the GigaPan program we're
going to be a big part of it along with
satellite imagery so I will not stand
between you and your wine any longer but
I'm happy to take a few questions if
you'd like
love to have some interactive
discussions of questions so all those
poppers it's a good question I mean
anybody can get a balloon they're not
ideal in terms of us being able to
provide them in some sort of scalable
way we're not there yet but maybe in
partnership with illa and others we will
be I mean we're working as are a number
of people on underwater heads to do this
I'd love to have a reef environment that
kids could meta tag that the world could
meta tag and could watch through time
through bleaching events and all of that
I wish there was a good answer to that
question I mean I think it's all about
being creative that octocopter you see
only costs a few thousand dollars and
you know you can buy a gimbal you start
to play with it that's what we're doing
looking for things that are light and
easy to deploy in the field and trying
to make them work in different
environments
no you know maybe we should at some
point but most of what we do is based
around scientific cultural and
environmental literacy and you know
publishing the tech specs of the toys
that we play with it hasn't been in
court of what we do and some of it is
just modifying off-the-shelf stuff
anyway so I'm not even sure that we've
got the right to do that but it's
definitely worth thinking about
okay the 3d giga pick big fans you've
been working on are they purely
perceptive 3d or does it actually create
a model that can be used in other media
so there what what you can take the data
and put it into a number of systems so
yes it creates a model that you can play
with in other systems definitely
prepares a catering from octocopter I
baseline
we're using a you know essentially two
cameras with stereo separation pretty
simple things
you can do that with any gigapixel image
I mean we used a robotic head and a
camera maynila can talk you through that
as can most of the people in the room we
used a robotic head to do a grid around
the room everywhere except where the
photographer was standing and then
stitching software to put it all
together we need to stop the questions
there because of the program
noun 1 we had a keynote gift for mark
unfortunately one of our other keynote
speakers is in the audience so he's
going to find out what its gift is so
sorry David we're finding out early we
have a very very thick very dry but
fantastic book by stefano derman about
the history of the panorama as a mass
medium device and that's been signed by
everybody in a create lab thing and then
we have the opposite end we have
panoramic a fold-out book for children
which when you fold it up has a panorama
25 feet long it wow so that's possibly
the longest printed panorama you can buy
in a bookstore
we have a couple of more orders of
business here before we can open the
gallery show I hope that the keynote
presentation was a wonderful way to fill
you with some inspiration and some
excitement about everything we're going
to be talking about I love having the
interactive component at the end we're
going to make sure that the entire two
and a half days is interactive like that
we're going to have a whole lot of
discussions and mixing of ideas amongst
all the participants and authors the
invited speakers and the invited poster
presenters now in order to be able to go
to the gallery we need to recognize some
of what makes it possible for us to have
such a thing as the fine international
conference and to have this wonderful
gallery show so what I'm going to be
doing is I'm going to be recognizing the
wonderful scientists who splits agri
photographic representations have been
recognized and chosen for the gallery
which you're going to see and printed
full size and yes there's my there too
and there's hors d'oeuvres as well but
we're really excited to introduce you to
the scientists who won the curated
gallery competition and won a place in
that gallery but to do that I've asked
to have the honor of the presence of
defines here now all of you keep hearing
me say the fine foundation and so it's
time to tell you a little bit more about
that the tripod that really made gigapan
possible was a initial collaboration
between Google National Geographic and
NASA and it was really those three
organizations that agreed to work with
Carnegie Mellon to invent a whole new
kind of technology and were always
indebted to those organizations that
process and in fact tomorrow the
speakers Alan Eustace from google
recognizing just as the day after
tomorrow's keynote speaker is from NASA
Dave korsmeyer that it is that tripod
that makes all of this possible from a
technological point of view but
technological funding has a limits and
that is the vision to fund new
technology is a high-risk endeavor that
we're very excited and thankful for but
there's a completely different kind of
vision that we need in our society and
that is the vision to take new
technology and take the risk of applying
it in completely new ways for
sociological good that's something
that's hard to do from the likes of a
corporation and that's something that we
up
two foundations for so the pleasure that
we have is in the relationship that
we've been able to build over the last
four years with the fine foundation the
fine foundation is the funder of the
entire program of science outreach that
Carnegie Mellon runs with GigaPan it is
that foundation that funds every
workshop that we have run over the last
four years and the international
conference this year is principally
funded by them together with some
corporate sponsors that are on the
program booklet so it's really because
their vision and their willingness to
invest in something that they can have
positive social good in the science
community and in a science communication
community that this whole thing can
exist that sort of our rez own death to
be here tonight is because of that and
in doing that I want to recognize two
people that we're very close to a
defined foundation first of all I want
to talk a little bit about Sheila fine
who's in the audience today Sheila has
been a real champion and supporter
through these years and has been really
excited to see how you as scientists
able to use gigapixel imaging the
handwritten notes that we've encouraged
scientists to write have been read to
write have been read by Sheila and mills
and I'm very pleased to say that they're
working they gave us continued funding
for this year so that's good to keep
writing those notes it is sheila's
compassion and empathy her intellectual
curiosity and her desire to change the
world for positive putt in a positive
way that have really made it possible
for the fine condition to have vision to
make this possible at the same time I
also want to recognize milk spine I'm
actually introducing him because i'm
going to ask note to join me here in
front of the stage where we're going to
give a bit of an award to each of the
gallery gallery selectees let me
introduce Milt first mills biography is
long and I've been trying to think of
the right word to present this the right
way to present this to me is to say that
he has been visionary both in the
business world and in the philanthropic
Foundation world and in the trustee
world of organizations like the carnegie
museum of art and the andy warhol
community he's on the board of trustees
of many key organizations he was a chair
of the board for the carnegie museum of
art he was also founder and on the board
of the Andy Warhol Museum which is one
of the most
museums that we have here in Pittsburgh
he is a chairman of the board the kind
of years ago he was as I said chairman
the world can use in part he's also
chairman of the fine foundation itself
which is the organization that makes
this conference and all the workshops
possible and I asked a milk to come up
to this stage and say a few words about
what they think of the entire gigapixel
for science inquiry that we've led over
the left yours may I ask you to come up
I want to thank Allah for everything
that he's done to put this program
together I enjoyed listening to the
lecture I have to say that I didn't
understand one of the questions so even
though the technology is beyond me I am
amazed and delighted with the results it
was a great pleasure to watch this and I
want to add my welcome to all of you I
know many of you have come here to
Pittsburgh to be part of this conference
and I want to congratulate all of you
for the wonderful work that you're doing
now when I first met ela and listen to
his plans and his hopes I was intrigued
by the idea of using a visual art form
to facilitate important scientific work
and since then gigapan has become a much
more familiar tool really around the
world for example my daughter civil who
lives in England work with Allah to
organize a conference there for European
scientists to learn the technique that
GigaPan makes possible running a
foundation is very much like running a
business in that you look to invest in
projects that will have an impact that
are practical and doable and one of the
things that I particularly liked about
GigaPan is that it tends to break down
wall
walls walls between art and science and
walls separating the various scientific
disciplines as one who loves art I'm
intrigued that gigapan is a technique
which presents very beautiful and very
stunning views of objects and life and
at the same time permits scientific
observations and discoveries which
otherwise would be very difficult or
even impossible the arts and the
sciences both rely on imagination
creativity innovation and the marriage
of these fields is in itself a very bold
and daring venture and it opens the door
to other kinds of collaboration and
sharing among the various areas of
knowledge exploration and creativity you
know in our society we tend to become
accustomed to separate silos and
separate labels we sometimes forget that
our civilization advances the most when
we share ideas and share concepts and
tools from a variety of sources familiar
and unfamiliar in academia and in
business and in government there of
course are separate departments agencies
institutions each dealing with very
separate and distinct subjects and yet
as we live our lives the lines between
subject
frequently are very blurry and very
indistinct we gain very much from having
a holistic approach to life a big
picture look whether we're trying to
solve problems or accomplish a mission
in the New York Times the other day
David Brooks read a very interesting
article some of you may have seen it
about American exceptionalism and I want
to read a quote from that article the
main point in this composite story is
that creativity is not a solitary
process it happens within networks it
happens when talented people get
together when idea systems and
mentalities merge now having all of you
here today from many different
occupations many different endeavors is
remarkable and it's constructive and it
points the way too much greater
achievement in progress in my own work
and in my business I've never been a
specialist of course one needs
specialties and specialists but I
there's very little specific that I can
do but I think I'm pretty good at doing
things in general and actually in our
personal lives and even in our business
lives we usually don't specialize life
simply won't allow us to do that we have
to constantly deal with frustrations
feelings emotions challenges failures
all sorts of issues and to do this we
need to draw upon sometimes philosophy
psychology economics history and many
other fields we need patience we need
resilience and we need wisdom to
navigate through life so we have to
graft all of those areas of knowledge
onto our specialties and while GigaPan
presents amazingly clear and detailed
images the meaning of these images and
their consequence is not always so clear
being able to break out of our silos
becomes a necessity so I want to pay
tribute to all of you for seizing this
initiative and for being able to see
what life through a much wider lens and
in this city where we pay some attention
to football I want to congratulate you
for advancing the ball considerably and
again I want to thank Allah for making
this possible and for being a very
multi-dimensional person who knows how
to turn fuzzy images and dreams into
very hard reality so thank you again
so we're going to ask the awardees to
come up I'll name them and perhaps you
can accept the certificate from milk we
made panoramic aspect ratio certificates
since your images are all panoramic and
so first from the Carnegie Museum of
Natural History we have eagle's nest
which was taken in Saudi Arabia which
you'll see upstairs and Richard bright
was the photographer he couldn't join us
so Chris beard and sandy Olson from the
museum and after history here will be
accepting his award on his behalf the
second one we have is you're going to
see a massive ball of fish upstairs the
paintball of salima and this was taken
by Jason book I'm who is also in the
audience so the actual photographer is
here in this case
next we have photographers both of whom
are here so we have two certificates for
them this is the entitled too big for a
sampling of the four mega diverse insect
orders you're going to see a whole lot
of insects upstairs thanks to andrew
Dean's in Matthew person
next we have a amazing scanning electron
microscope of barnacle a single barnacle
made extremely large much larger than
any barnacle grows and the picture was
taken by Molly Gibson and accepting the
award on her behalf is Jay langson
next we have a very unusual picture it's
a picture of reality except it can't be
real reality you're going to see a whole
lot of hummingbirds even though there's
only usually two on one a beautiful
brigham homebush upstairs and this was
taken by Chris fasty who's in the
audience here
we have twin work we have a from Sierra
the enmity oh it's a picture that you
will enjoy and it was taken by routing
lists next we have yet another fine
fellow we can call them fine fellows
when they're fine fellows and their
inductees of the fine program this is a
picture by dennis van tingles door and
Michael and Ray they would both come up
and this is interesting because it's a
picture of a giant panorama of an
unhealthy be frame from inside a beehive
that is the conclusion of the
programming we're going to have in this
room I'm going to invite you now wow
we're 30 seconds late sorry I mean I
advise you to it to the preview opening
of the exhibit which will be open to the
public as of tomorrow morning it's
upstairs on the third floor am i right
three yes okay I'm seen shaking your
heads so go on upstairs to the third
floor there's hors d'oeuvres and drinks
and you can actually enjoy all of the
GigaPan aromas up there thank you again
for attending the very beginning